Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab in a couple of days ago, as in like seven, we uh,
we were on stage at the Brooklyn Academy of Music. The big opera house there.
It's a really beautiful theater and it was full of more than 2000 people.
We were part of something called Radio Love Fest.
Yeah.
Radial ofs is a,
a big public radio broadcasting radio lovey thing that w NYC station here puts
on.
Basically it's a parade of all these amazing public radio shows and podcasts.
We opened the festival and since it was called radio love fest,
we figured we would use the opportunity to basically talk about the community of
people around radio lab that we love, the producers, the musicians.
We features amazing acts like so percussion who you're hearing.
A lot of stuff happened and we told a lot of stories today.
We're just on this podcast. We're going to play two stories.
These are both stories about love and about heart.
The last one which you'll hear is a,
is an exclusive interview with Oliver Sacks.
Basically giving a kind of valedictory interview. It's pretty wonderful.
But first we decided to do literally a look at a heart.
This comes from our producer, Molly Webster.
It was scored live by a soap percussion, which is Eric,
Chad beats, Josh Quillin, Jason Trudy and Adams Lewinsky. Oh.
And some people in the audience in the theater audience had a pretty strong
reaction to what you are about to hear.
And we are not so sure that that might not also be the case if you're just
listening. So if you are driving or you're operating machinery,
maybe this isn't the best piece to listen to because it can get a little
intense, which we'll talk about a little bit afterwards. Uh, in the meantime,
here's producer Molly Webster.
So this is a story about a friend summer ash. Uh,
we used to work together and I think it's fair to say that summer has a
complicated relationship with her heart. You know, my heart was not beating
for three hours.
Really crazy thought. Yeah.
Technically,
I don't know.
[inaudible]
so a couple of things to know about summer. She's like wicked smart.
She's an astrophysicist. She uses a lot of big words, propulsion,
center of gravity and moment of inertia, x and Y, Z axis.
Do you remember that original like radial keratotomy like no,
I don't even know what that word is.
The other thing to know is she's an engineer, right?
So she loves like take things apart.
You sort of like coke around rewire ratchet.
You got a ratchet. Uh,
and so the thing to know is when she found out she had to get heart surgery,
she made sure there was someone in the operating room with the camera taking
pictures of my open chest cavity and the valve and when things were cut and when
things were being sown in y. Yeah,
I totally approached this completely as a scientist. I want to know
what's happening. I want to know why. I want to know what you're doing.
I want to know what's going on around me.
And in any case, as sort of backup and explain, um,
summer was just following up on like a heart diagnosis that it had happened
about 15 years earlier. And so she had been diagnosed with a murmur,
which is basically just like a funny sound in your heart.
And that's like a whoosh in between the thump, thump, thump, thump.
And in summer's case, she had been told it's no big deal.
And so this was just a follow up appointment to make sure nothing had changed.
And so she goes to the doctor, she,
they run a few tests and then they send her on her way and a few weeks later she
gets an email saying,
um, don't panic.
[inaudible]
but I think you should see a heart surgeon.
It turns out the situation with her heart had changed her aorta,
which is like the largest artery coming out of her heart.
It was larger than it should have been.
So it's supposed to be about two centimeters in diameter.
And in summer's case it was five. Yeah. What does that mean for your bodies?
So that's the thing,
asymptomatic, it's not actively harming you,
but it's a threat to your life because if it ruptures,
it's your main blood vessel. And if it goes,
you bleed out internally so fast that no er can help you.
Okay.
Her doctor says go find a heart surgeon. And in the meantime,
no heavy lifting or contact sports in summers. Like,
well I live in New York, like living in New York as a contact sport. Yeah,
I was gonna say people crash into you all the time. Yeah.
Six months later, summer finds herself on the operating table.
They actually, um, I think, I'm not sure the exact order of operations,
but they
open her sternum from the bottom all the way up to the top and then they just
like, oh, he pulled back a rib cage so they can get EQ,
her heart,
they put some sort of fluid on it that stops it from beading and they actually
sort of just inject that fluid into the heart and that short circuits it
so your heart actually stops and then they hook you up to a bypass,
a heart lung bypass machine.
And one of the things that does is it drains the heart of all it's blood.
And so it's like flat, like a pancake.
And you can see pictures of all of this on her blog.
You can even see pictures. It's true.
You can even see pictures of the a surgeon cutting four inches out of her aorta
and replacing it with the synthetic tube and the entire time summer's heart is
just
limb in quiet.
Eight hours later she wakes up.
Yeah.
What do you remember about your first conversation with your doctors? Oh,
I don't remember my first conversation much,
but I do vividly remember my first thought part of my friends was,
fuck, this hurts.
Just mind altering pain.
Oh my God. Eight hours ago I felt so much better than this.
Can we just go back to that now? Like, no, I don't want this. You know,
everything pulls on your torso and so when your sternum has been cut open and
then reconnected, everything that pulls on that hurts.
You can't move anything or lift anything. It hurts to talk.
It even hurt to breathe,
but literally from day one they make you stand up
[inaudible]
and start walking. Really. I was like, she was like,
we're going to get you to sit and chat. I was like, no, no, we're not.
What are you talking? What are you smoking? And that's just to,
that's just to basically, you just got to get the heart going again, you know,
just get it healing.
But here's the thing, when it came back,
it came back with a vengeance. So to be fair,
her recovery went really well. About two months in, she's in cardiac rehab,
the pain is fading. She's thinking about sending her mother home.
Her mom had been staying with her for awhile and then one day she's in cardiac
rehab on the elliptical machine.
And so I remember stopping and I had this white tee shirt that would literally
like just be fluttering
[inaudible]
with my heartbeat. Like it was blowing in high windows or something.
And I was like, well that's interesting. You mean that you could see it?
Oh yeah. Yeah. Even the physical therapist there could see it. They, the they,
you mean like you would look down and you'd see the thing,
your heart beating through your chest wall,
pushing your shirt off your chest? Well, because I'm a lady,
there was a gap here.
So like that sort of there a space for that vibration to happen, so to speak.
[inaudible]
but then she goes home and it was still happening.
Okay.
Like just sitting on her couch, not even working out. She's like, Whoa,
my heart is strong.
It just felt so strong that I, part of me was like,
am I going crazy? Like is it as strong as it seems like it is? Because if it is,
surely this is making a noise. So one day,
a few months after surgery, she goes to upstate New York,
she's visiting some family friends and she's hanging out with their daughter
Julia.
She walked in and we were standing in my room,
they're just chatting and then suddenly Julia's eyes get really wide.
And I was standing there just, oh my gosh, I just want to skirt it.
She could hear summer's heart out loud two feet away from in the room.
And I was like, okay, this is happening. Uh,
so I guess in typical summer fashion, she's Kinda like, let's engineer that.
If a friend of mine can hear it with their ear and what could a studio pick up?
So she grabs her radio producer, friend, uh,
they go to a studio and he sticks a Mike about six inches in front of her chest.
And this is what they recorded.
This is not a stethoscope. This is what it sounds like.
If you were standing in a quiet room next to summer, God,
that's strong. What does that feel like?
It just feels as if my entire ribcage,
my clavicle, my sternum, my whole chest cavity is acting like an amp.
And it's sort of transmitting the vibrations of each heartbeat in physically in
my body to feel each RP. Yeah. Do you feel it right now? Yeah.
You can just feel that thump, thump, thump. Yep.
It feels like somebody has a rubber mallet and is banging on the inside of my
start and it's very staccato.
When she goes back to the doctor, she's like, dude, my heart.
So he sort of just did some like listening and some feeling [inaudible],
you know? And his reaction to it was like, yeah, that's strong.
So we run some tests and he's like, listen, your blood pressure's fine.
All of your stats are fine. So I guess I did a really good job. Yay.
Good for you. But, but okay, I guess I have a strong heart. Yay. Strong heart.
But I don't want to feel this all the time. The doctor was like, Whoa, Whoa,
whoa. Don't freak out. This will go away.
It's probably just that there's scar tissue on your sternum and it's
transmitting the vibration and is that goes away. The sensation should fade.
He said sometimes six to nine months is when maybe the Scar Tissue Heals more
thins out. So she's like, all right, nine months. Oh I can get to that.
That's no problem.
So she sorta just settled in and treated it like a scientific curiosity,
like a party trick.
If I went to a restaurant where they had like tables for two but they weren't
like the sturdiest of tables. If we had water glasses on them and I,
I sort of leaned on the table like the water glass would look like Jurassic
Park.
Like my heartbeat would be like the footsteps of the tone sorcerer.
Yeah. So that was like my party's strikes.
You had six months of Alation trick and then yeah.
And then it stopped being a party trick it sounds like. Yeah.
What happened and I'm not really sure like you know incident wise,
I think for me it was just time passing
cause that nine month mark just came and went and it was still there and when
she asks her doctor he has no idea why.
So 12 months still there,
15 months it's still there and she says it just started getting really annoying
if it's distracting.
The the funny thing was the more active I was than the less aware of it I was.
But she says when she was at her office trying to be still be still to either be
writing something, writing emails, planning lectures,
that's when it would be like
really loud. That's when it would become the most dominant thing. Like I,
I couldn't go to work because it just kept drawing my focus and when it did it
would just feel her with anxiety. It was
sort of this like automatic response, and I'll try and explain it,
but it's basically like when you get scared,
it goes into your brain and then the signal goes down into your body.
So you step on a snake and your brain is like, oh my God, it's a snake run,
body run, and then your heart pounds. In summer's case,
it was just the opposite. There was no snake, but her heart was pounding zero.
Her brain would be like, Whoa, why is my heart pounding? Oh my God,
is there a snake? There must be a snake run, body run,
and her heart would pound.
My brain keeps thinking something must be wrong because we're having,
we're already doing this, so something must be wrong,
so I guess something's wrong, so let's freak out.
She was caught in this feedback loop and then she was like rightly so,
edgy and prime that any emotion on top of that, like even if it was happiness,
which is too much. Oh my gosh, yeah. Nights. It would keep me awake.
I would focus on it.
[inaudible]
I would get into hearing the rhythm, feeling the rhythm
yeah, sort of with the expectation of just
the next one. Next one.
Next one. Next one.
Next one. Next one. Next one. Next one.
Next one. Next one. Next one.
Next one, one next one. Next one.
Next one. [inaudible]
with every beat.
Our hearts are just literally tapping out time and I mean researchers actually
thought about this and there was this idea that was proposed like a right before
the dawn of sort of modern heart surgery that we each get 1 billion beats in our
lifetime and then that's it.
And most of us don't notice them going by,
but in summer's case she can't not notice it.
Yeah, I'm aware of it always. It's never not there.
It's never not noticeable that,
I mean it's just like this constant awareness of the future that summer is
endlessly meditating on.
My heart takes over and I can't do the things that I want to do and not knowing
if that's going to last forever or if it's going to end suddenly or if it's just
gonna Peter out. The not knowing gets to me.
So she stopped going out as much as she stopped returning phone calls except for
like a few close group of friends.
The Times were just being curled up in bed and just crying.
A really wanted to yell at my heart, shut up,
stop when you really talk to your heart. Well,
I mean I would never had conversations but I would be like shut the fuck up.
But it wouldn't
and as time went on, like the constant pounding,
it just became unbearable.
She describes it as like this alien creature is like trying to just claw it's
way out the bottom of my neck.
[inaudible]
but there was this one moment right in the middle of all of this.
She had her two year checkup post-surgery and for that they had to take a
picture of her heart.
So I schedule my two year appointment and to look at her heart,
they do an echocardiogram, which is basically, you know,
like the ultrasound like that you get for the pregnant. Oh yeah.
It's like a little,
a little wand and you get the jelly and they basically go all over your upper,
you know, the area around your heart and from all different angles.
So what ended up happening is I'm lying on my left side and I'm facing the wall
and the technician's behind me and the technician is sort of like reaching
around her, waving the wand over her heart.
And the monitor for the echocardiogram is behind summer so she can't
see it, but she's wearing eyeglasses.
So you know how you can sometimes like see a reflection,
a peripherally on your glasses of something that's like behind you.
Like if you were in a somewhat darker room, there was a window,
like you would totally see the reflection. So the room's a little bit darkened.
Summer's lying there on her side and she sees the reflection of the screen,
um, on my glasses and it catches her eye because it's moving.
And then I realize what it is that I'm,
I'm seeing a tiny reflection of her heart beating and I have this like moment
[inaudible]
I have this moment where I'm like, oh my gosh your,
I'm like talking to my heart and my head going, well we had your working hard.
Like you're trying your hardest, you're doing the best that you can.
I'm, I'm doing the best that I can.
You're in there and you're working and you are working for me and we are on the
same team and I just totally like, I just silently start crying.
No
like what do you think spurred that on?
Like what was it about seeing it or there's just something about physically
seeing it but feeling it at the same time.
Like knowing that I'm seeing what's happening inside me that somehow just like
clicked this understanding into place.
She said there was something about seeing it in real time,
like feeling this thing in her chest,
just pulsing in rhythm with what was happening on the screen and then suddenly
it just,
it didn't seem separate from her anymore and all those worries about the future.
And what was going to happen and wasn't going to go away.
And I mean she's just stopped. She was just like, no,
you are just beating and that beating is me. It was sort of like,
it was sort of like this moment of,
of recognition of its purpose and its work and and sort of this,
so it's kind of like that whole idea of when you feel like you see somebody not
just physically, like you see who they are, you see what they are,
but you see who they are. Like I had that. Like I felt like I see you heart,
like I see what you're doing, I see what your purpose is. I see.
I see you
on the one hand, what she sees like with her engineer's brain is,
oh I get you. You're just a pump. And it's that same, you know,
realization that essentially led to modern medicine, right?
Like the minute we took the soul out of the heart, we were willing to touch it,
to cut it open, to stitch it up to start fixing things.
And now we have lifespans that by some estimates are 2.5 billion beats.
But on the other hand, like when you hear someone's heartbeat,
your parents or your child's like in that beat is an entire lifetime.
It's a, it's a history of beats. It's a series of beats yet to come.
And I dunno, thinking about all that, I just,
I just sort of got walloped at the end of this interview. Um,
when summer asked us if we wanted to try and listen to her heart.
Can we try that? Just see it. Do you want to? Yeah. Oh, that's just moved then.
Like, or I'll stand up or something.
So she stood up from her chair and she started put her chest right in front of
the mic and then we all just got really quiet. Okay.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
[inaudible]
oh my God. Wow. It's just me. It makes me really emotional.
Every time I hear it, it makes my eyes, well, it's here.
It's really amazing. I guess I still got
kitchen art.
You Go. Yeah.
So give it up for radio lab producer Molly [inaudible].
[inaudible]
yeah. When you said earlier that a lot of people in the audience had a strong
reactions. Here's how we met. I mean, I don't know if you could tune this in,
but like when we were doing that story I was definitely seem like something's
going on out there. I can tell cause we were on stage, I couldn't, you know,
this is their 20 I definitely was tuning in.
There's something going on in the audience, something going on side stage,
but I didn't really know what it was.
We were in the middle of it walk off stage and the first thing we hear is that
numerous people had fainted, even vomited during that piece. We were like, what?
Seriously? I did not see it coming. No, we were really,
really scared at first and I thought, oh my God, am I, am I killing people?
Like it was just like, I was like, were they old? Were they young? Like what?
Like why they were young and that made me say, Oh okay.
They feel like weirdly a little bit better. Maybe they can handle it. Yeah,
I just was, and then I was kind of weirdly mortified. Terrified.
But after we figured out that no one was hurt, we were like, we got,
we were like,
we would start putting out and we started making some calls because we were
like, what was that? What do we make of that? Just like, oh, I didn't know you.
So the show is over and we all go home. This is days after this.
And you're thinking, oh my God,
we're gonna Cause I'm thinking we've got a podcast, this damn thing, right.
We have to, we have to understand this and say something completely right.
So the first person we called was a psychiatrist,
Rachel Yehuda, Mount Sinai School of Medicine, Department of Psychiatry.
I explained to her the basic situation that,
that some people had fainted and felt woozy. We weren't quite sure how any
five or six people out of 2100
somewhere between five and a 12 we don't have a,
a clear number just yet.
That's very interesting.
Do you have any sense of what might've caused this? Just like a guess.
So my best guess about that would be that they have activated their
parasympathetic nervous system in response to hearing the heartbeat.
No, just to explain.
Our autonomic nervous system is divided into a bunch of different parts.
You've got your sympathetic nervous system,
which is sort of your fight or flight, right?
Sweat turns on when you're scared and then you've got your parasympathetic
nervous system,
which is sort of the opposite rather than getting you ready to fight or run,
it makes you calm.
And Doctor [inaudible] says that in certain people that parasympathetic response
can actually kind of go overboard and their Lud pressure can drop quickly too
quickly and they end up fainting.
Now the most common, um,
stimulus for this to happen in,
in real life is fainting at the sight of blood.
Some people just do that and it's not that common.
About two to 4% of the population have this kind of a response.
And we don't exactly know why it happens.
There is some opinion that the idea of fainting when you see blood is an
adaptive evolutionary response
that you know, maybe back in the day when we were being chased by predators,
it would have been a good idea to faint
because maybe the animal will think you're dead.
Then he'll skip you. He wants a live meat and you're dead meat.
Exactly sees you lying there and he's like, I don't want to eat that.
[inaudible] throw. Another theory is,
this is also an evolutionary one is that if your blood pressure drops like it
does when you faint,
well that kind of protects you a little bit because you'll have less blood in
your arms and legs. So if your arms and legs get bitten by a lion,
say then you are less likely to bleed out. Let me see. There's nothing,
there's nothing juicy to suck on if your blood is on,
not in your wing or your limb. Yeah, basically. I mean who knows?
These are just stories, but going back to the two or 4% thing,
we got to thinking two to 4% of our audience that night would be,
what do we decide Molly was like 40 people, 44 to 88,
44 to 88 people at 2100.
So we put out some emails, uh,
looked at the incident reports and I think now we have identified how many,
what do we get? So for us, we've heard of maybe 10 or 11 at this point,
10 or 11 now. But I think that based on some of the stories that are coming in,
that the number might actually be much higher than that. Um,
for example,
it's just manifested itself physically in a way that I could not have imagined
would be the case. This is Maria Cha Veco who, uh,
actually works down the street from us, uh,
for the company that makes Latino USA. I was sitting in the front,
uh, against one of the walls, but not right at the wall. She says, uh,
she was listening to the story. Everything was fine at first, but then she says,
as the beat kept going, she began to worry,
what if it never stops? What if summer never gets away from it?
And then the drumming got more intense and it was just like, oh no,
oh no.
And it was definitely the sense of being trapped that the thing that was giving
her life, which was absolutely necessary,
was also the thing that was tormenting her.
And she says that she was thinking about that.
She just kinda got short of breath.
And so I looked at my husband and put my hands up like,
like I gotta go. And he looked at me, he was like, are you all right?
And I was like, I shook my head like, no. And um, and I,
and then I had the talk in my brain like, okay,
this is an intimate radio moment. You are right in the front area.
If you get up six people have to get up with you. What are you doing?
You're ruining this for everybody. Just breathe and it'll be fine.
And then the deeper I tried to breathe, the more anxious I sort of got like,
oh, and I had this fantasy of like standing up and doing like a really
look to wiggle it out of me, but I was like, that's
just got to suck it up and so Jeez, look at that.
I'm having trouble breathing just thinking about it saying,
I don't want to put you back there. No, no, no, no, I'm fine. I'm fine.
I'm fine.
What my hunch is that there might be a lot more than 10 because maybe a lot of
people just sort of pushed through and didn't get up.
It still felt weird knitting case.
One of the most interesting things that we bumped into is that Dr you who told
us, it's very possible that the fainting in the wooziness
be some kind of an empathy response.
Really? In what sense?
Well,
if you hear somebody's heart beating and you're aware that that's what you're
hearing,
it might arouse a tremendous connection within you of hearing the very source of
their life. Yeah.
I became her. I did. I just, I was there with her.
Can really be a lot to take in and you feel a little faint or emotional.
I just identified so much with somebody being trapped in their own body.
It's like she couldn't escape. It was beating in my chest.
The drums I felt were beating in my chest and in my crazy fantasy,
you know, maybe they were breeding at the same rhythm.
One of the people that emailed that to the live show said that he felt like his
heart was trying to match her beat and he couldn't catch his breath.
I don't know. I have, I don't know. It's never happened to me before. No. Wow.
I asked her a in the end if she'd ever want to hear summer's heartbeat again and
she said, oh yeah.
In fact she said she was going to listen to the story as soon as it was
podcasts, which is now because now she's got all these questions.
Like was it the acoustics of this space or the fact that she was with so many
people or maybe it was the volume cause it was pretty loud and will I feel the
same when I hear it? You know, with my headphones on or, you know,
while I'm driving, will I have that feeling?
So I had already decided that I was definitely gonna listen to it again.
We'll let you know what happens.
[inaudible]
sure. We got a break. I just want to say this. So percussion,
who provided all the music so far? Um,
they've just released an album called music for wood and strings written by
Bryce deserter of the national. This is what you're hearing. It's,
it's kind of an amazing piece.
Yeah.
If you want to check it out, go to soap,
percussion.com we'll also link to it from [inaudible]
radiolab.org.